welcome to argument clinic a guide to
spotting bad arguments on the internet
in this episode we're gonna be talking
about ad hominem a classic logical
fallacy what's that
you don't think ad hominem attacks are
that bad well you wouldn't think that
because you're a of course you're
not a I'm just demonstrating an ad
hominem attack which means trying to
refute an argument by attacking the
character of the person making it rather
than the logic or premise of the
argument itself oh boy okay now where
can we find examples of an ad hominem
attack
it's rubião there must be one around
here somewhere he said he's got
pathological disease he actually said
pathological temper and then he defined
it as disease come on one of you must
have seen somebody respond to a critique
by reflexively attacking the character
of the person raising it rather than the
substance of the argument he has the
news conference all the time when he's
eating I have never seen a human being
eat in such a disgusting fashion okay
to be fair it is not just President
Trump who resorts to ad hominem attacks
anytime someone dismisses a protester by
saying they're paid by George Soros or
argues that anyone who supports Trump's
immigration policy is racist they're
using an ad hominem attack take a look
at any comments section and you'll find
tons of ad hominem attacks ad hominem
attacks are not always wrong sometimes
the character of the person making an
argument is in fact directly related to
that argument if for instance they're
making an argument based on their own
authority and they don't have any if my
buddy Daniel tells me that he learned in
med school that it's totally healthy to
eat seven pounds of beef stroganoff a
day it would be perfectly valid for me
to point out then he never actually went
to medical school and is in fact an
electrician but for the most part people
make ad hominem attacks to avoid the
argument altogether let's take a look at
a few different flavors shall we so
you've got ad hominem tu quoque way this
is when you accuse someone of not
practicing what they preach for instance
when a carnivore tells you that eating
meat is bad for the planet the fact that
this purely hypothetical meat-eater
can't resist a savory bowl of beef
stroganoff does not invalidate the
argument and then there's ad hominem
circumstantial in which you try to
invalidate the argument by
claiming it is within the arguer is
self-interest for instance if I present
data that proves that tax cuts are good
for the economy it would be a fallacy to
dismiss it just because I'd benefit from
that tax cut and then there's poisoning
the well in which someone is primed to
distrust someone else's argument in
advance for instance the way Donald
Trump called a bunch of press outlets
enemies of the American people
the day before news broke about some
members of his administration's
communications with Russia you get the
idea ad hominem attacks are easy and
they can be kind of fun but they are not
sound they are dodges a way to avoid
grappling with the substance of an
argument itself you don't agree will
free to hop on the next train to loser
town because that's obviously where you
belong
[Music]